Watch as we step through
knitting a basic short row sock
knit from the toe-up.
To keep things simple,
I chose to use a solid color.
But I'll bet that you can be a whole lot
more creative with your yarn,
color and stitch pattern choices.
The first place to start is to knit
a swatch and establish your gauge.
Without an accurate gauge,
how do you know how many stitches
to cast on and how many rows to knit?
Knit a Swatch.
'Nuff said. One of the reasons to knit a toe-up sock
is to control of the amount
of yarn you need.
There's nothing worse than running out
of yarn part way through the second sock.
With a little planning
that won't happen to you.
Weigh the amount of yarn
you have in grams.
I'm starting with 168 grams.
We'll come back to this number later.
Next, plan out the size you want to knit.
Measure the foot length
and the foot circumference.
Determine how long you want the leg.
Depending on the amount of yarn you have,
you may need to adjust
the leg length. Again
this is a reason for knitting toe-up.
Once you know your measurements,
enter them and build your Knit it Now.
Dynamic Pattern. Before doing anything
else, read through the entire pattern.
Identify anything you might not
understand, and look for techniques
that you may need to practice.
In the READ ME section,
we discuss the placement of the toe seam
and knitting a right and left sock so the
seams end up on the inside of the legs.
Okay, let's get knitting.
Scrap on the Toe stitches. I used
a green crochet cast-on rag
and knit a row of ravel cord.
This will leave open stitches
that I can graft later
to complete my toe.
We'll knit one row and then short row
shape the toe according
to the pattern instructions.
If you aren't completely confident how
to knit a sock toe or heel, there are
videos available showing some options.
Please take time to watch the videos.
Once the toe is complete,
scrap on the remainder of the
stitches needed for the foot.
The "K" dimension in the pattern.
I've used a crochet cast-on rag again
and one row of yellow ravel cord.
Leaving open stitches that will be grafted
to the previous cast-on edge
to complete the toe.
With all the foot stitches now on the bed,
knit the foot section.
You may want to add a stitch
pattern or change colors.
Remember, get creative.
Notice that I added some markers along
this long edge to make
it easier to seam later.
Once the foot is complete,
scrap off the first heel stitches.
Short rows the Heel. This is exactly like
the toe short row process
rehang the scrapped off stitches.
I left my waste yarn in place,
but you can remove it to make sure
you've picked up all the stitches.
Note the stitch count on your pattern
to double-check.
Knit a few rows according to the pattern.
I like these extra few rows between
the foot and the cuff for the ribbing.
They seem to make a better fitting sock.
Now that the foot is complete,
weigh and record how much yarn you have
left and we'll tell you how
much yarn the foot used.
It's time to knit the cuff,
leg or ribbing.
You have lots of choices
if you want the whole cuff in ribbing,
you can hand-manipulate some ribbing or
hang a ribber cast-on comb
and transfer stitches to the ribber.
I chose to remove the knitting
on a circular hand knitting
needle and hand knit the ribbing.
Before starting to knit my ribbing,
I grafted the toe stitches.
If you aren't fussy, you could just pick
up both sets of stitches and bind off.
Because the seam can be a little bit
bulky, it's best if you plan to have
the toe seam on the top
of the toes for comfort.
I plan to knit my ribbing in the round,
so I used mattress stitch to join the side
seams, matching up the yellow markers.
While I was knitting the ribbing, I kept
track of how much yarn I had remaining.
I started with 168 grams.
The foot used 34 grams.
Now that I'm close to my desired leg
length, I'll weigh the ball again
and confirm that I have
enough yarn remaining.
Or maybe I can knit the leg
a little bit longer.
My leg used 14 grams.
So far I've used a total of 48
grams and have 120 left.
No worries about running out.
I'm going to make my leg a little
bit longer and add a rolled edge.
Instead of worrying about a stretchy bind
off in ribbing, I'm going to knit a few
rows in, stockinette
and then just let it roll.
This is a quick way of adding some style
to my sock, and I'll have
a stretchy bind off.
It might seem like socks are complicated,
but with a little planning and taking
it step-by-step, they're not hard.
I hope you'll give toe-up socks a try.
You'll be glad you did.
Happy sock knitting.